and wonder may arise Wonder may arise
lack may arise there's no hierarchy of
what's better than what this isn't
saying that there's a hierarchy and
wholeness is better than lack that's not
what's being said all that's being said
is that wholeness is the only thing that
is and then within that is the apparent
lack and that apparent lack is what
apparently creates mutually assured
destruction okay that's all that's being
said and through this message of what's
being said maybe that ucer sense of lack
will hear it and it'll relax a bit and
it'll stop creating mutually assured
destruction and it'll create from
wholeness that's all that's being shared
here and no one's doing it